greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
September 24th the podcast is brought to
you by on it
you know me dog everyone on it for years
now I love their products from the
shroom tech sport the shroom tech immune
you know me I'm flying to Boston this
weekend I popped like angels and mutants
on the plane cuz you don't know who's
gonna be on the plane far and is you
know know and you know was gonna be
prepared but anyway gonna add a.com
right now press ENTER CH and get 10% off
your order
listen football seasons and [ __ ]
hightail the Cleveland Browns won after
2000 [ __ ] years you know knowing one
just lost two in a row you could be
making money you understand me like Joey
how am I gonna make money you know how
my bookie
listen it's not watch your bed as
important as who you bet with that's why
I always tell people to bet with my
bookie
I only recommend a service to my
listeners that's been good to me the
church family that's why I'm urging you
to make your way to my bookie you win
they pay now this is what we're gonna do
this week my bookie so slammed would do
better throughout the day what they're
gonna do is then what you have the best
service possible so after seven o'clock
they're gonna give you an additional $25
free play deposits over a yardstick
that's a hundred olives so go to my
bookie calm right now
my bookie will match your deposit dollar
for dollar use promo code Church check
this [ __ ] meal League let's happen
you're bad [ __ ] uncle Joey here
it's a beautiful day to be alive I got
guys that want to be on the podcast for
the last [ __ ] 10 years but I just
don't bump into you as much no he's
[ __ ] we made it man again thank you
for having us I was the weekend
everybody dude I don't even know if
weekends exist anymore
it's like it was common every day yeah
7:24 take a little for me the weekends
are the worst because people are out man
I do [ __ ] during the weekday cuz
everyone's working yeah cause I mean you
go out and do [ __ ] you live the workweek
is basically a weekend as a comic and
then you know you've kind of you kind of
reversed it's it's weird that the
[ __ ] they sold this is kids yeah
it'll work 3500 weeks for a lot hands
gonna work ten hours a week
over time yes Saturday we had a mole the
Lord until that Sunday you got pretty
much everyone was yeah that's it
everyone we know that does it doesn't
live that lifestyle don't know out here
no not at all yeah people don't have
class that way no yeah no these other
people don't have that technical is
celebrities coming over the other day I
make it a big [ __ ] deal but I'm
talking about just that was a dream that
was sold to us they needed to sell it
though in order for us to become
consumers to run this [ __ ] economy
but that's the dream we were so I'm
gonna work five days a week and have two
days off and put money away and then go
on a cruise ship and hope the bungalows
in hit an iceberg anyway you wear the
shirt and tie during the week sweater on
the weekend with khakis that it's weird
it's a it's a it's a [ __ ] up day when
you come to realize that you gotta work
Saturdays or Sundays that's a that's a
[ __ ] up day like when you usually have
to learn it most people learn it like at
17 or 18 some [ __ ] is learning
at 14 like I learned that like at
fourteen and Saturday and Sunday
cartoons but the cartoons yeah yeah it's
over I'd say no more pop no more [ __ ]
Popeye we gotta get up you gotta go to
the Bronx and run around the
neighborhood make sure there's no cop
cars and they put it [ __ ] like that you
know with you then yeah then you start
with the [ __ ] Sunday then you go to
college or whatever you realize that
you're in the library on Saturday and
Sunday you really are you doing homework
and if you're really doing something
you're gonna librarian Sunday Saturday
oh you want a group of people doing so
yeah but you're you're hungover and you
realize that all over I can't really do
the [ __ ] work so at what point do you
realize that the American dream the
40-hour a week was [ __ ] you know I
meet people out here to have three jobs
legit you know a morning job or [ __ ]
two nights a week they do something good
on Saturday and Sunday they banging out
ten hours a day in a coffee shop
spur and that's just the cover rent car
payment and a [ __ ] comedy show once a
month yeah you know think about that we
gotta throw family you know you this
thing shifted like I always knew I
wasn't
me a positive influence in the regular
workplace I always do I knew what at the
ages that did you ever have a
nine-to-five job ever
I really tried to be an American I
really [ __ ] tried but I knew as a kid
I like my mother's lifestyle I'm out of
all the businesses she worked nights
there was something about that phantom
in the daytime with everybody else's at
work that got my dick hard
yeah you could do whatever the [ __ ] you
want so she would do was an hour's worth
of work from 9:30 to 10:30 opened a bar
a bartender would cover and she'd boogie
out of it she'd go home finishes she was
doing at home cats the afternoon mech
game go home cook dinner and then jump
back into Jersey at 6:00 and it worked
the bar - oh sorry were you always up
late as a kid yes seelix from very young
you were you had late oh yes and then I
always had a problem sleep then what I
did get to sleep and she would wake me
up at 3:00 in the morning but she got
home anyway it's only about a day and
maybe yeah so I was always you're you're
being groomed for comedy no I didn't
mean uh I liked stand-up
I like prior the album's but I thought
it was always like a faraway goal or far
away back then it was I don't know how
many people watched it was like hey I
can do that where now it seems a lot
more accessible obviously with podcasts
and how much stand up there is then it
was it seems such a far away thing to be
like didn't even say I want to do
stand-up people that forth the [ __ ] are
you talking about in the early 70s it
was David brother it was Richard Pryor
it was George Carlin and a couple other
guys and Freddie Prinze came along there
was a couple other guys that you knew
from The Tonight Show if they were gonna
be uh yeah then you'd stay up there was
no DVR and no no yeah you [ __ ] missed
it yeah just take a piss man you better
hold that so growing up in New York you
had the honeymooners at 11:00 and then
the out couple 11:30 so from 11:30 to to
12:15 you'd be physically pushy you know
0 11 1 1 4 there was no rewatch
last channel last chair though there was
no we'd have to use when you're a kid
watching softcore porn if anyone was
Alice was in the house you'd have to
have your last channel queued up to
something that you knew what it was so
if they walked in the room their titties
you could go to that lat Oh watching I'm
TV eh what are you talking about this is
everything's cool to the other of your
dad's have VHS porn because I had to go
I have to remember the time where it was
in the wine to make sure one day oh well
let me tell you this so we had a motel I
grew up in a motel my parents owned so
two special customers they'd give him a
descrambler and so my dad would have to
go downstairs in the basement and change
the porno movie out like every hour so
we'd be watching Dallas and he'd be like
close your eyes at our commercial
because he had to check to see if the
porno was done but he'd watch it for
like four or five minutes before so I'm
just [ __ ] watching this I'm like four
years old watching pornos and then he
would go out the movies almost done so
we got to go downstairs and change the
new pornos so you grew up in the hotel
yeah so I did nine-to-five job because
my mom would run the motel during the
day and then my dad would stay there at
night and so then we used to live there
and then once my little sister was born
we got a house in town about a mile away
because you're just too small you always
own cual though it though Oh 24/7 for 35
years my mom really [ __ ] you see the
hotel Jesus man
I mean a lot of times my mom would be
like hey I you go check to see if this
if this guy hasn't checked in in a few
days nobody's seen him I go in there and
the dudes just dead either drugs self to
death or [ __ ] suicide I mean
everything that you can imagine like
what Yogi's in the 80s people would stay
there like families would stay if you're
on a road trip and then the 90s people
started going who's in Valparaiso
Indiana which is what's the closest
Chicago's like 60 miles away Wow so it's
like but it's pretty rural we had a guy
he [ __ ] the chicken to death in the
early 2000s then there it was like a big
piece like Leno did just in your town no
no in the in the hotel oh my dad found
the feathers and like the carcass and
[ __ ] what was this guy wearing Aloha
oh no he's [ __ ] chickens again and so
he called the guy's mom cuz the MA
guys mom it put this guy guy was and
he's really [ __ ] off you can see a
picture of them online
the one eyes down like below his
cheekbone those people with the
fucked-up eye and they're not just
people with those sleepy eyes and
everything
I got a sleepy eye that's why don't we
were sleeping looking in the mirror yeah
it's [ __ ] up but the sleepy I wasn't
doing the coke they didn't get the
Sleepy Eye from doing more silent my
right eye
we just started yeah I got a droopy
eyelid too I got hit in the head with a
2x4 that's nerve damage that is [ __ ]
crazy frightened people oh yeah
the last thing I ever wanted to do is
find somebody dead from either a gunshot
wound or a suicide I probably saw
somebody hanging them I would [ __ ]
well that'd be yeah my brother found a
guy who killed himself this is like
early 80s he's probably like six we had
geese in the backyard so in the morning
he would have to let the geese out and
so we saw a guy in his car who would
later we'd found out committed suicide
he ran a hose through the tailpipe and
this was probably like 83 and it turned
out he had AIDS and this was like before
anybody knew anything about AIDS so this
guy just thought he was done so he
killed himself and my mom had to go
clean out his trailer and she was like
none of you guys can come in here cuz I
don't want you guys to get AIDS cuz
people thought it was [ __ ] airborne
people's they get it from a toilet seat
so she was just like but somebody had to
clean out the trailer and rear end it
how old you were maybe five 84 85 I was
like six season how old are you in 85
for yeah nope 308 III I was uh five five
years old a member the biggest so
obviously of invades care mm-hmm people
lost yeah I remember even in the 90s
like with magic Johnson people thought
he was he was a goner but by 91 it is it
was still but 8086
oh that's when they were talking about
like handshakes and [ __ ] you might get
it from a [ __ ] ham like it was still
[ __ ] you know poor gay men we're
getting [ __ ] abused but it helped me
cuz that's what I got with the prison so
they built the aids unit
and that there were six beds but they
had four of them in the bed I like for
gay guys with HIV in the unit so it was
it was it was wrong it was two units
that with two rooms that were open and
there were two units that were open and
I would hang out there like everybody
knew that I got the age of it because
they explained it to us there was four
guys I had HIV so instead of people
being weird to them they came out and
would talk to us about it another four
guys were gay well that's what they told
us at the time they told us they have
been all got it from intravenous use and
you know listen I don't have HIV so I
obviously hanging out with them you know
but it was really like that's how even
prisons don't give a [ __ ] prisons don't
give a [ __ ] they worked a year behind
schedule
you know jack when they came to HIV
everybody was [ __ ] quick fast like in
a way it was kind of like government
don't believe it it was in a way it was
like let's build something to get away
from these [ __ ] people like here's
this prison camp that was their sister
Lincoln was there and right next to it
all of a sudden they built this
beautiful [ __ ] six room condo with
[ __ ] the kitchen of microwave
refrigerator and you know and the whole
[ __ ] deal it was just it was
tremendous to watch I don't know what
the [ __ ] that we're talking about stuff
though Duffing they have to get the HIV
to get into the nice digs
yeah the tough face I'll be a friend of
theirs and go hang out yeah crazy is
this that those guys got me through that
prison sentence yeah it's like it was me
him there was a four or five of us that
hung out full-time the HIV unit
and there were two particular guys that
had HIV then they bugged with us and
they were hilarious the one black we
were gamble we would gamble big in there
they controlled all the gambling wheel
control the third of the gambling of the
prison and the one black guy that had
HIV would just talk to you and you
couldn't beat him up he would just go
Danice it looks at your team who who'd
you bet the Browns it looks like and
they know what sort of fat lady sings
but she's busted a limo right now and
even go I can't talk against he would
just plug people to death he would just
keep uh-huh oh my god there was the
there was a Mexican guy that was like
the original leader of the Mayans oh
they're [ __ ] like the motor side like
he looked like it the whole thing yeah
he had the tattoos everywhere but he was
a heroin guy and the HIV guys were still
doing heroin in there nobody bother like
that's how much people didn't care leave
me [ __ ] with that damn how many guys do
you think who you did time with I've
seen you on something like that [ __ ]
I don't think anybody you don't think
anybody should quit I'm getting [ __ ] you
know how expensive our needles like why
is everyone sharing needles all the
goddamn time because when you're getting
all right when you get a guy and you're
in that [ __ ] world
you know us three go Kapil it's like the
way we smoke a joint
we share a needle don't you listen
[ __ ] scary li hua Shan needles no no
I still shared needles now and they know
[ __ ] you think back then they didn't
know [ __ ] [ __ ] needles so I don't
know anything about that world but it's
weird that that's when you get nine you
know that's long gone yeah yeah you got
four guns yeah I don't think the
priorities are you know let none let me
make sure I doesn't me I just met him at
the train station okay I just met him at
the train station North Hollywood he got
me he got me to a guy that sold me a $4
bag H and part of his thing
is that he gets a taste so now we walk
over we get them in each other
you're from whatever Boston of Jersey
holy [ __ ] your Boston Red Sox are like
the Yankees we come over here and it's
just like when a guy tells you he's got
HIV we come over here normally all right
you I go I don't have a rink I don't
have a rig and I haven't used in 10
hours so I'm gonna look you're here we
go
he looks like a pretty toy right he's
from Boston I mean what kind of him can
he have what kind of disease come here
it's the same as not using a condom it's
all the [ __ ] bull but also that
shooting ten years from now I got a call
okay a little dizzy I go to the hospital
they tell me I have HIV and I go yeah
but I'm not gay yeah I know you know
yeah we know that know whatever you know
however gets transmitted that's how
that's how quick it is well did you hear
about the I forget the name of the group
but it was like punk rock artists in
Cuba who specifically infected himself
with HIV or AIDS till like they got put
in till you like some housing with just
them so they wouldn't get messed look
over at a guy he's like I got [ __ ]
HIV and they give me all these benefits
who knows who the [ __ ] knows why I did
[ __ ] I don't live in Cuba so I can't
tell you maybe finally think you might
shoot myself with another local CVS I'm
saying I want the heavy-duty flu shot
today give me the one other rats give me
the one that gives you [ __ ] coughing
foot so let's see them saying so I could
really complete the [ __ ] process I
don't know why where do you get this
[ __ ] Lee you have too much time on your
[ __ ] hands to read this are you a fan
of his fancy this [ __ ] no I'm trying to
feed a family ain't got time to look at
the Vice no Cuban I don't give a [ __ ]
but some people like people send me like
videos I just put a thumbs up and keep
moving on with my life yeah your [ __ ]
video I got time I press that thing they
say no I voted for Trump and Russia I'm
saying you don't know what you change
suddenly
I always think you have the weirdest
allegiance to [ __ ] just because though
all this time yeah who the [ __ ] has to
learn I wish I had time just sit in
front of a computer see who's tweeting
what and what I don't I get out of there
I say what I got to do move the [ __ ] on
yeah sometimes somebody calls me go hey
I just sent you the details I tweeted it
to you on a Twitter the message stay and
I'll look at that off
it will of the address to the podcast to
do but besides that I don't go I don't
read of the articles on the [ __ ]
computer do I give a [ __ ]
if it's not on Yahoo when I click in if
it's not that first article yeah you're
out and I even give you a who will extra
second to click in that second one you
know I'm saying yeah the first is always
some Trump [ __ ] then the second one they
show people running in a tropical storm
that's it
Yahoo's always the same it's just clicks
on there's no more Kardashian stuff know
this they don't give a [ __ ] anymore
you got to scroll down as far to get to
that [ __ ] I don't even scroll like the
what's world news day cuz they have
better like a family person and at 6:30
you can't just run out on your [ __ ]
family so you sit there you put TV on
and I like I like the old lady the
blonde lady for [ __ ] 10 years I like
that Diane Sawyer
now she retires she moved on she went I
did to you somebody last week Sally
Field big Yahoo and I was really excited
about seeing that would I enjoy it says
Burt Reynolds didn't doesn't she have a
book out or something - at the same time
she dated Burt Reynolds right there man
yeah she married no I just see her
everywhere now that uh once he passed
away keep seeing stuff about Sally well
[ __ ] Sally Field looks like a million
[ __ ] bucks
Oh dick she's a plastic surgery now I
think she let it go naturally she's
[ __ ] right dudes
you look at like Elon Musk you're seeing
that dude duh you see what he used to
look like what he was like 21 just [ __ ]
bald dudes now got hair plugs looks like
it's chin implants all this [ __ ] yeah I
saw just won't enjoy that crazy that
[ __ ] obtained of the shock price it what
that did for me was let you know that
podcast now people gonna pay more
attention to punt yeah yeah that was
just a step up with Obama did better
we haven't Obama didn't baron that was a
step up for people
yeah like [ __ ] Obama did bear and
that's a pretty step up now Yvonne bus
goes out rogue and smokes to join them
Rogan I don't get that just gave podcast
on that part thank me the television
industry where homeland no Lou yeah what
are we doing yeah I couldn't get them or
they couldn't get the smoke on World
News Tonight she quit on even vice count
to smoke [ __ ] yeah old marijuana channel
what's another one they got [ __ ] you
guys do what I Rogan took the joint in
the joint of it when he had been doing
it for years his eye opened up you look
likely I think that just upped it for
everybody
oh yeah man think was that same week or
the week before Marinette Paul McCartney
yes it was like [ __ ] don't mean a sewer
them that's true imagine that like that
podcast caused a multi-billion dollar
company to go down like six [ __ ]
percent I mean that's what a [ __ ]
pound a week ladies are world news
ladies other people to the moving people
ascended up yeah no he I don't think
it's gonna affect on crazy I don't get
the short-term thing and I wouldn't get
a listen listen to me there is no way on
earth that they don't let somebody
irregular go up with the [ __ ] the
Chinese billionaire
listen to me doesn't better but the
Chinese building the island here who the
richest guy in the world this that play
will blow up like with that school
teacher
hang on fire I'd never forget that thing
going up me going she's never gonna make
it I swear to my daughter mercy that I'd
never got a premonition like that before
I remember still being what I was in the
video store in Snowmass Village Colorado
and I was working and I had the TV and a
bunch of people walked in and even
before they lost I go that thing is not
gonna make it just they don't want to
get the burn you know book the idea
gonna listen to this guy what's going
around and say it I didn't say it yeah
when they all started yelling to the
finger the pin it's going down the
school teacher from Florida is dead
that's a message yeah okay yeah I was
watching that live in first grade yeah
we all the teachers are like we all
let's turn that off the [ __ ] law that
killed people but it by heart
I swear to God I knew that mission was
never gonna be complete because they're
not gonna let that happen
their cells work spent billions of
dollars you just have [ __ ] to the
[ __ ] fool regular Jones yeah but Elon
Musk keeps failing at a [ __ ]
self-driving car you gotta trust a
rocket ship to the moon you're [ __ ]
it up he's really what do you get in
that car though
well not even a million dollars not even
for a million dollars when I get in a
self-driving car [ __ ] that is the
dumbest white people [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
world you gotta be the dumbest you know
what's that thing they call white that's
supremacy privilege privilege Charlie
[ __ ] never let you get in the white car
you deserve to [ __ ] die yeah four or
five for a trunk to jump the HOV Lane
and to catch you for your karna gold
flames don't ever let that happen either
don't ever let that happen me you can't
make it don't ever let that happen in it
because that's what other [ __ ]
that'll be responsible for one [ __ ]
accident or a week one of those [ __ ]
stupid cars or somebody takes over the
grid and it's responsible for like
200,000 people die yeah well that should
never happen
this guy's to home care if it's a
Chinese billionaire that day will get
shot down before it even starts if you
think Ellie's head blew up with that
[ __ ] bullet hit him wait till you see
that rocket blow up and there's a
complication and it's set back three
years and by next time nobody wants to
go to move but your [ __ ] business
never happened well there's people who
signed up to like be the first group of
people don't move tomorrow's permanently
yeah I know people who sign up to get up
the Aspen Shaquille pick up the [ __ ]
[ __ ] either you need some old-school
guys like those badass guys the first
guys go to the moon like those guys
could handle some [ __ ] I'll tell you I
can bet all you [ __ ] I could
disappear for five years and come back
and some bars vacations on [ __ ] late
night TV like I'll come up in midnight
with my vacation
my uh my brain is uh operators out there
right now waiting for your call here's a
brochure the buzz it be just finally how
many pamphlets you would send that
yeah and how many people you were close
and gonna deposit on I guarantee you I
would get if I said that I've had your
pamphlets a week I would close 20 of
those people a week that's how good I
have especially now at this age I don't
give a [ __ ] I was killing people in the
phones when I was 21 I can't imagine
what I could do to you now want the
[ __ ] phone with [ __ ] Mars time yes
Lawrence
let's grab your American Express card
this is how easy this is
well good it's it's $50,000 I'm not
looking for $50,000 we're looking for a
$20,000 initial investment down payment
yeah but my internal easy attorney can't
see anything cuz your toys and talk yeah
because it's your trip to Mars and think
you're [ __ ] crazy okay
this press card it starts with a 5 I
think it starts with a 5 let's discover
whatever
what's it start with how's you and every
time they reject you what's your name
starting to Carl its Hosea right give me
the J how does it start jack you just
keep close though and I will get 20
[ __ ] to sign up from waters
trips and never see that's Joey Mars
dear Joe if you let me see them say yeah
yeah let me I'll send you whatever you
want there's enough people out there did
the [ __ ] morons
we're still people at home that are
taking calls that are going to the bank
and paid somebody on the corner because
the IRS is coming to the house yeah
problem there's still people paying
people online they get emails that
they've inherited a million dollars but
it went through London you gotta pay a
Nigerian call my Luc below $100,000 to
be a [ __ ] in Africa there's people that
fall for that dumb [ __ ] every day I see
it I see people you know I totally all
the time why he hasn't borrow 20,000 and
opened up a podcast in school and put a
picture of Joe Rogan be like Joe Rogan
and Papa Joe boys already put billboards
all over Hollywood but what in front of
the grumblings were little shitty improv
[Laughter]
you know dude yeah that's it
yeah but you don't want a door do the
late-night talks sell all [ __ ] tapes
of you teaching people out of pocket you
have no idea why you're not back clean
up when I first got acting teachers as
acting teachers get their balls friends
right
and this is of dad writing a check
because it's gonna move but get the [ __ ]
out of here
well you think Queen Latifah learn how
to move an ice cube with the getup have
to make it a feeling you just cannot
fathom it I'd bet kids along the way
that Toby that I would bump it that
seven years later like you still go to
acting class yeah she told me I'm not
ready yet I saw a guy that wasn't ready
for ten years then he became an agent
good then he got a little business
altogether ten years things I've spent
for six years of another topic and then
forward the other ripoff school or La
Brea and think about those stand up
classes too it's like how are you gonna
teach anybody how to do [ __ ] stand up
I wouldn't pay for one of those but I
wouldn't pay it I wouldn't pay 50 not
over $50 I pay for a $50 stand-up
workshop from a [ __ ] working job yeah
but very happy how that's the teacher
very rarity bucks is the most you should
pay for a three-hour seminar on
something yeah but some of these are
like multi-week memory needs to do the
belly room was it Greg Dean's comedy
school it was break me [ __ ] I don't know
appeared somebody shot him gave me his
book wants on stand-up comics they used
to work the phones when they would do
that and I mean it's just it's not I
think that a cowboy needs a little
guidance we want to ask a couple
questions the beginning or just do a
show like a veteran comic this is a
friendly invite they give you that very
friendly first show where it's all the
students go up so it's it's kind of like
a padded I don't wait thirty five bucks
for three weeks unit
yes that's not for that was three hours
every Sunday for three weeks he covered
comedy stand-up then we did a
performance if he gave you a little bit
critique did he it all try to like
stifle like if you say you had a joke
that was like really you and they're
like well I don't know if that's gonna
[ __ ] work while you do hey I look
like so-and-so had a baby or something
did they ever general that thought it
was really basic 101 okay open up with
your second best joke closer your best
joke it was the teacher his name was I
just you know what I think he's pissed
at me for something so good summer I hit
him up on Facebook he's done it
that's why give him a while he's in
Florida teaching improv classes some
[ __ ] you know one of the number one
state yeah he was like he was like a
stand-up guy did early on he with the
chips and his wife were like a comedy
team that were part of him and his wife
wife like part of an improv troupe that
was like Fleetwood Mac everybody started
[ __ ] everybody else's wife it was like
when I first joined up with him yeah I
took that as a continuing education
class at the University of Colorado
would you get it to like just get over
some just get comfortable on stage
because I mean stand-up as an art form
like you know you're gonna have to
[ __ ] eat [ __ ] for years a lot of
people don't forget I've heard have you
ever heard comics I've never bumped one
I know comics that destroy everything
yeah all the time that's how you know
right there will they tell you that yeah
okay good but you've seen them and
you're like yeah I'm watching but yeah
yeah you destroyed what about the guys
that you see you landed they tailor
destroyed and they haven't written a
joke
yeah just using that for years or both
of them was that really scare the [ __ ]
out of me
but all the guys that you've seen on
their HBO special in like the 80s and
then you see him and they're doing the
same [ __ ] which what do you guys worked
at the store well both did yeah we're
here that you get that he started we
both I showed up there I moved here in
2003 early 2003 he started working at
the store what a year before me yeah I
was there I started working in 2003 at
the store I did the open mic for like
nine months started like Thanksgiving
ish 2002 and then yeah I got hired
probably like nine months later to work
you work there for four years talk of a
regular should be yeah she was at that
weird time where you know she was like I
showcase for her I don't know a dozen
times and every time she [ __ ] did
nothing it's the worst and you bet
you've ever used to go front like it was
the only time you I ever had like
shortness of breath and your [ __ ]
like you're like this never happens
wheeze and she's in there and the way
she would ice that room I mean you would
be like you'd be like a child who's like
you never did stand-up before they would
we got high I got hired there after him
and it this was it was a different era
there there's no audience is there
really at all nobody dad that Dean
Gelber ran it MIT's he wasn't coming
around and Tommy would come up to you
MIT Wow
Mitzi's coming in tonight you guys have
to showcase for your jobs hey wait wait
illegal now would you think about like
this [ __ ] so to keep your job you'd have
to go up in front of MIT see if she'd
you not that you can lose your job
because of a bad set and so you'd be
terrified and you would see you know
like I'm a right I remember seeing Chris
Rock look in the room and he was gonna
go up and then he'd turn the corner so
I'm Mitzi and her see she always had it
out he was gone it's okay I'm good
thanks yeah I'm gonna go hi live this I
love I don't know what the guy's famous
he's still around I get up there I'm the
host on a Sunday like when we started
you were host the Cuban egg roll the
viewer stage behind the curtain I knew
how to get behind the pool Ari Shaffir
once hit me in the balls from behind the
curtain I was on stage I figured out how
to go from behind the curtain to the
stage and take my dick on it yeah you
get great laughs back there no I did it
to somebody and she bummed everything
she Bub's the 20 [ __ ] years up there
but you just liked it because there was
some about it there's a those and I took
the curtain and I got completely naked
and she was on stage there was like like
that's when there was scattering of
people yeah 23 scattered in the room
which sucks dick in the original room no
it's horrible and I would just open up
the curtain go like this like with the
curtain opens I would just close and she
would think she was flying my god she
was killing and I got dressed up went
out there and watched her like shake
everybody's hand like oh my God thank
you
you killed sua da Barris come please
[Laughter]
Saturday but we don't know exactly
Sunday that up down there and there's a
guy with a wig that was it
if you're missing a [ __ ] up eyeball
are you missing a foot I'm whichever you
don't cop if you're in a wheelchair but
if you're gonna make him a wig it's
gonna be a tough night this was a
[ __ ] rug that was a good rug it was
an expensive rug but it was a rug yeah
then about the door and in those days I
took every year beaten imaginable
because I was she used to let me host
the tend to close so I'm getting every
comic in America chucking me up we
hosted there we host the other magnet
for you yeah Holly told me I could come
in and get a [ __ ] spot yeah it's
[ __ ] my uncle's Dean's landlord told
me to come in tonight it's [ __ ] crazy
but then what you see I don't have time
you've never lost a friend so fast he's
like he's telling me that he just opened
up for a run white and he blue run wine
off the stage hug sit there those days
like I was already hip that's great yeah
no I won't think of the mileage doing
this rock I can't wait though I think
roughly gets here I can pull him up
because I was I remember you used to
leave you'd be like halfway through you
required you and I figured it out I was
doing give it over to dog bear I'd give
it the batteries you would get your [ __ ]
in and you get where Joe and your
[ __ ] goat are without you got no
driver from uncle Joey you know so I'm
listening to this guy it's an early
Sunday up there early I'm that hosted
I'm hosting Ted well it's like 7:00 and
he's waiting because he got he got some
of you offered my job as a doorman
so sure enough
whoever gave the job as a doorman he
puts his t-shirt on and he is [ __ ]
sure he's been a doorman an hour and
they say that you want to go up and he
goes yeah I just blew off Ron while
stays with all this [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
I'm sitting there and actually what
happened just to see what was gonna
happen to something come on I've heard
every [ __ ] story actually they I told
most of them saying yeah I told half
these stories you gonna tell me these
[ __ ] stories but especially their you
know you know the o.r is gonna give him
a beating all the original was giving
him a beat he goes up with his comedy
store sugar at the one minute mark
she's in the back going [ __ ] AWOL
lying in why them whining oh my god he's
got a wage line here you can hear her
you can hear it
she fired him she fo yeah yeah he got
off the stage they go you fine take the
t-shirt off he threw at the batter just
thank you take your wig and go well he
was pissed he walked down their block
yelling at the Comedy Store [ __ ] yo I'm
a great [ __ ] coming she's put PTSD uh
people that's all that was PTSD but you
want to see it watch comedians and cars
when Shandling in Seinfeld he takes him
to the comedy storage and Seinfeld's
like I don't want to go there you could
see it in his eyes he's like because she
wouldn't pass him anything I don't want
to go in the building he convinced him
and then he went in and that's when he
came back whenever he went back to the
comedy store he's like oh yeah this is a
good room [ __ ] yeah it was it's also I
love the comics too that are like oh I
can't do three minutes I'm used to doing
45 I can't do three minutes okay let's
see how the workouts I tell the three
goes I see how that three goes not one
laughs that's weird
it's [ __ ] will you see a lot of
stanhope wannabes the two thousand and
she would throw them off the stage and
then wouldn't that we gotta got it and
they would do stolen material sometime
these store comics in front of it that's
when you should be shot like and most of
those comics are in the room so it's
like that's mine that's mine
Toby he stole this whole thing of
buildings and the whole room turned on
for the [ __ ] he shot huh like
everybody's like that was one of my
favorite Bill Hicks [ __ ]
why would you wear a cross around your
neck that's the last thing Jesus was
seen by the balls to say that joke and I
would be like my goose hairs went up and
half the rubles like like not that that
you know you could steal but ain't that
way they'll take that yeah she was like
cannibal of she drew on this other kid
that came up here to be the next Bill
Hicks out of Houston she threw him
imagine you get tossed that and then
when you get tossed out of there you're
done good although it should go over
forget that his manager walked in with
him but let the walk out he walked out
this manager huh was 10 feet behind of
that why that is funny of humor like
that relationship had the other played
that's you know I couldn't imagine do
you do the open mic at the Comedy Store
did you know cuz I couldn't imagine just
going in there like cuz you know that
room is such a [ __ ] weird vibe to it
like we started out doing the open mic
for a long time like the there's a level
of comfort you have to get in that room
before you can [ __ ] make that thing
work for you like God we were open mic
with the legends the back when they did
like the freak show up mic so Gaylord
Engler Scottie bear
you know like I'm for talking the og
what happened to Gaylord Ziggler why was
I accuse the bird investigators see if I
burden touched I know there was a guy
Mickey his best friend who needed the
hitting up with a beer bottle of the
head in an alley and left them we
thought he murdered him it's a Mack
Lindsay actually like went to the police
to try to like have this shit's all that
Lizzie was the kid with the nosy and
yeah yeah he's in New York me Tommy know
why we're in New York what's he doing he
is a phlebotomist so he takes blood at
hospitals and he's like going back to
school very bright dude the dude runs
very smart he runs like 80 miles a day
he got out of stay of them back now
still doing a little bit he was great
when I saw me as he was a great writer
but something was not there and I heard
they told him to leave it was almost
like if he was doing really well here
try to push it to the right they asked
him nicely was but he's [ __ ] funny
man yes it was actually funny yeah but
Gaylord Ziggler Ari Shaffir held the
trial when he was hosting you held a
trial for this guy Mickey well did you
kill him did you kill Galen and he held
the whole trial in front of the whole
audience they've got a documentary the
other gaylord to be way to see if I
killed
how are you associates would that be
really Gaylord Gaylord would very to
lamentable well if it was one of those
periods but he used to torment what
would he do to you just talk to me
thank you bye thank you I just asked me
stupid my hands constantly when I was
like this well I had 18 pounds when I
needed 25 they're gonna half a gram of
coke well that was $7.00 away the last
thing I need it was a question
Gaylord England well he would ask me 50
questions are they was it him you would
throw ice at was that the count or the
Scottie Baron wasn't one of them do you
hate it was it Scotty somebody got you
you got you were you should get into it
so some if I dig it maybe it was Gaylord
cuz if you say that he was always [ __ ]
with you however always you'd come in
and throw ice and somebody walked across
the stage I don't remember who it was
yeah if you were there early you would
go at it listen though you got a figure
from 97 when I walked in there to about
2000 the screws weren't really tight if
I look back at it like the screws would
not tighten yet yeah the the the
criminal instincts were lowering and the
comedy conflicts was getting a little
higher but I would still select your
[ __ ] throat like I was still Robbie
if I had to like I still get a lot of
creepy little things that nobody do at
that time but at that time I was still a
little bit of the crazy side then I had
the beef with the guy who I told not to
touch the [ __ ] microphone
it doesn't take it hurry you do copy the
books what think about doing copies
being intelligent and being courteous to
the guy behind you you'll never nobody
nobody nobody nobody ever tell you I run
a light yeah yeah without like the
bazaar that means to get the [ __ ] off
into what the [ __ ] minutes that's it
what'd she do that you're disrespecting
what we're about
yeah so I'm very this is a very
respectful to a comedian okay but you
want to lose my respect do dumb [ __ ] if
you're sitting there watching him on
stage and you see that dodo keeps
hitting the microphone and it's
elusively there'll be a favor when you
come up don't touch that [ __ ]
microphone I don't give a [ __ ] what you
fall for okay you're gonna break the
[ __ ] break because no no over here he
ain't coming back ever like don't worry
about he ain't ever coming back here we
already made a note at the back that he
[ __ ] broke the microphone so now you
gotta up here you know touch the
microphone so I'm sitting in the back
and I tell the kid do me a favor
don't touch the microphone because it's
about to break there's a hundred people
on a Sunday night yeah we've been
working on 64 people every Sunday for
the last two oh boy yeah this is then we
got a hundred and twenty
don't touch the mic what do you think
this [ __ ] what I've been dead
[ __ ] broke the show for six minutes
it you might as well [ __ ] the room and
stab somebody that shows all about
momentum it's right yes yeah when that
guy had a plan he couldn't good open
bakers are going up and they're [ __ ]
improvising and that bar bigger that it
provides the bomb and you're going up
there okay yeah you come to say a couple
funny things you get those last you for
the next guy up boom
this [ __ ] laughter I told him
now here's the other part of that story
I get it I didn't pick up a color
because I follow the rules
yeah but you see that the [ __ ]
microphone is with some rules are your
string is Billy mics are from like most
mics were from the Kinison arrow they're
all yeah they were dented inside dice we
bought him and then ro Rogan did ro get
reboiler yeah so Rogan paid for the
system nice paid for something but that
night when he got off and I got off I
went up to like a man they go hey Ben I
ask you like a man not to touch the
microphone to a verbal tirade at me that
ended up that way no for him with a cube
or table they had it wasn't a pool table
foosball one it was that food boy was a
foosball it still has pulse picks yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I know you're
talking about right I got [ __ ]
miniature one where they call vers la
hoy and said they were there threatened
me I took all those put a little my
pockets but without the flower plants in
the front I took every knife from the
kitchen go bartenders get cut Elevens
every drink was given that night with
[ __ ] no weapons in them I had every
knife in the [ __ ] building and I saw
them make the left turn onto Main Street
and I saw them pull out water pistols
and as they're about to through water
pistols at least one of those cue balls
at they're called indepted and they
[ __ ] ran off into the night I think
all the Hinds County store they call the
police are being everything yeah I had
beefs from those [ __ ] Monday that are
Sundays because it was a thin life a
line between better house now boom
Shakalaka
you could tell they let hit but on
Sundays for spinner at day right yeah
yeah what he is you could tell they let
him on Sundays to see the birds and
different colors I never had a problem
with him I also got accused of like the
one guy on fire what day would lock
himself bathroom wage a nap oh no oh I
provide
yeah he's accused us effete I gotta
qualify everyone did you light a bonfire
in the bathroom I'm out of the [ __ ]
state stop accusing me of doing [ __ ] to
people
oh no they locked a bit they patrol the
paper the window they live on fire and
he said they're back at the [ __ ] door
did you let him on fire at a different
point or no no now we can always lock up
in the bathroom that was a given
we always like that as soon as he got
that well up table Heineken I don't
drink in heaven water there was a night
where Robin Williams was in there in the
store and we've been working there for a
long time and a provider who is he
Mitsy will let him close the open mic
for like 25 years so he saw Robin
Williams coming to all these guys come
and go but when they would come back he
was like stuck like a [ __ ] mosquitoes
stuck in the amp you know like from
hundred years ago doing the same bit so
we see Robin Williams watching him from
the back of the o.r and there's nobody
in there are it's just Robin Williams
involved the back watching Bob if we're
standing in the back hallway you know
Neil goes you ever see this you remember
this guy and he turns to us and he goes
no I've never seen that guy in my life
look like he saw a ghost and he [ __ ]
bounced out of the club we went outside
of the where'd he go he was he
disappeared like he was in rehab three
weeks later he was spooked it was a
[ __ ] he was [ __ ] knew that he knew
him because Dodd said he used to do an
impression of that provider and he's
like oh yeah he knew him and so yeah I
think seeing him of like my life is gone
so far in one direction this guy's been
stalking this same exact spot doing the
same exact there was a couple people who
have been to health issues yeah it was
very heavy but without one Sunday nights
yes it's changed a lot has changed a lot
that's how we were able to stand out
just cuz we were normal goggle guy you
were their employees so it was a little
couple of employees that world above the
crazy side white dudes yeah it looked
like leather skin it it was like four
and one little more deep the back oh oh
yeah yeah this is the ID seven and then
they cleaned up a little bit the store
cleaned up but
a warranty of the open-mike side of it
stayed it's [ __ ] crazy
there's still some crazy people who I
see it open they cleaned it up though
compared to what it was it was like it
would be like sometimes it was no normal
people because you don't need to draw
those numbers so sometimes it would just
be all insanity there was a tire that
was really pretty they used to show up
sometimes on Sunday nights
this is 2099 because Sunday nights were
cool because it was open mic from 7 to
10 employees and friends from 9 to 10 mm
so then you had the professionals from
10:00 to close and I would host that and
bring up Eddie Rogan or moody dice one
of those guys dated an hour then
everybody else went up but it started
getting popular especially Sunday nights
with what they would be off no those
were crazed those are the crazy ones
when we would host the og paid regulars
would come in and demand that go up if
they knew it'd be a [ __ ] mess
so those nights were always crazy there
was a little run that what was the
Japanese girl that came in for a while
and the black guys took her in ate her
up and spin around a lot ha ha ha
yoku real cute I go I go she's not
around oh boy this would Tamayo what was
it so bio was all this yeah then what
came in like a mm been pretty funny she
started getting spots but she's leaned
over to the [ __ ] freaky birthday side
and she ended back in Japan with a black
baby right like they the [ __ ] that
pregnant to death nobody knew who her
father was nobody knew what the father
was she was scratching there and idle
Dutch man laughs right before we got
yeah she left there was it was crazy
down there but there was a girl that was
show up and I didn't put this together
to her like a year afterward because
everything was moving so fast and you
tried to decipher different characters
yeah
so they nights mud days there's such a
different character character there what
was the old school guys and just Wade
they were there for McKenna some days
ah they would sign up on Sunday said
nobody would really talk duo was the duo
there's there's a couple you talk about
Piper itself do you remember those two
dudes Piper and tougher no they were
from like a whole over from a whole
nother era and they came back they were
there was occasionally some people that
would show up and be like I was here
then you know they tell you their story
or like yeah I don't I don't give a [ __ ]
man it's not on that list this is my kid
now he's 18 he was like it was written
by the other side of the building when I
worked a lot you'd have guys come in
like that and they begged you know who I
am and I beg I just start working here
like - no I've never seen you in the
ballet you got to piss piss do you know
that you didn't know who it was he like
I've never seen you in my life that was
a crazy girl over there so did I - the
wig oh there was a coin did she end up
in the big dog shell blue iris oh hey
boy a granny boy a pretty girl real
pretty
24 open biker she would always pull up
in a cab and go in and then she would do
her set in the way and she was pretty in
the way when she took the wig off she
was even prettier but then one night
like she couldn't be like you're the
host yet she wanted to be it she gave me
a ferocious ear beating you could trade
spots yeah people do anything to get
anything anything it was such a crazy
but I still remember certain what was
the woman girl go but the Mercedes
and she had fake tits and the doctor
didn't do it right so there was no shame
in her tit that was gigantic up at the
top of the tip the tip just go natural
news she wasn't even that attractive but
they did the fake tits for her and she
had a yellow car like a yellow OH
yeah I think tits but yeah up here like
that she delivered Mexico yeah actually
right and they put about dog neck right
under the Colorado took this vein for
the tit you stab that vein you'd kill
her yeah it cost too much to run it
underneath the bus she put it over the
[ __ ] you get spots just let Sundays yeah
either you talking about I have an idea
that could be completely off and I'm not
gonna say that's it I think I know
Barbie yeah was a Barbie yeah no I was
in a different direction
oh we oh yeah I know you are going
different Mercedes same thing do you
remember the bad oh this may be of one
time but you know what some people's
bits you remember but useful instead a
bit about doing [ __ ] wheatgrass a
shot of wheatgrass if you made it out
your door to the garage your you had to
pull out your pants you took a [ __ ] so
big it look like ally of justice
we grass for a while because of my bud
no matter how much coke I did if I drink
a shot of wheatgrass and had some sushi
I was nullified she'll say yeah I system
is me being and yang yes I would blast
out two of those [ __ ] now they called
III like though it's a completely now
grab it no wonder you can eat hot
anibal's if you're drinking like branch
of the day they give you they just would
rip off a piece of grass yeah you just
do a shot of it with something else and
it would clear out it was like getting
frozen yogurt and looking at it going
Jesus driving over one night like I
don't know what then I had to stop
I could even bigger that's the night
that I wrote the joke about so I had
like two shots of it and then I went out
and a whole were like oh my god I got a
[ __ ] but I've never really make it
upstairs that's right don't forget this
and I pulled up to my driveway and I go
visibly one way to get away with this if
I shoot the garage so I open up the
garage door and when I win and I forgot
to put the headlights up so here I am
we're taking up it around
ankle this shit's up up and blow out of
my ass I got the headlights I'll be had
a run with my pants around my ankles
turn the headlights off in the middle of
all that I turn around and they just
blew out of my ass and a ball will break
one of those things here's a guy and you
feeling my stomach trading and every
intested just raining out and I [ __ ]
like looked around there was some rags
had my pants on right like staggering
out of there it was like I'm trying to
be cute it was like I got [ __ ] in the
ass by 20 bags at a party like I was it
that night and they all [ __ ] because I
could they had [ __ ] equilibrium by the
base like I had [ __ ] so much that the
equilibrium had been out of my body
that's how sick I was like I got up and
I was stumbling around that I had to sit
my car
hufflepuff and I had the headlights off
so I just drove it over it that was the
tired and I'm saying like over it like
it was like crying like right I'm just
talking up the evidence so I drove over
with the car like that wherever I was
sitting my [ __ ] was right under it like
my burning simmering outlets closing the
door and walking and then like going oh
my god my wife's gonna get the car at
the border you shouldn't see this [ __ ]
and walking back and I could still smell
it I'm not going back there oh my god it
was horrible and when I walk downstairs
I mean my wife was sitting on the couch
and I walked right to the bathroom and
finished like the other 20 ounces that I
had left like a but she goes what is
that smell like that's how bad it was it
was it came from outside
it came though it came yeah it was
followed me it was like it was [ __ ]
my clothes
you know flowers get stuck in your
sweaty yeah yeah it's still somewhat my
ass - this [ __ ] sweats that fart is
trapped between the way away
it's a [ __ ] have you guys ever peed
your pants and [ __ ] your pants on like
on the way to a gig or at a gig don't
have to do a head no I almost didn't
happen the other day smashing pants on
though on the drive there I didn't
identify I don't have to cancel
the sill you didn't piss or [ __ ] him I
didn't how do you have to pay you didn't
you couldn't just pull over and just
[ __ ] no no I had to [ __ ] oh and I'm
not gonna do a friend of ours [ __ ] [ __ ]
his pants and then did a commercial
audition with uh with his pants he
farted and then [ __ ] his pants and then
he took his be with the bathroom but he
had he [ __ ] through his underwear and
then the back of his pants had like a
dime sized speck of [ __ ] which he says
dimes eyes but if he admits dime that's
at least quarter and then there was a
bunch of kids at this audition because
he was auditioning for some kids thing
and so he gathered them all around and
he's like hey kids
any you guys smell [ __ ] alright I guess
I'm alright does somebody smell
something that's what I always say so
I'll put up with that one they said
means something else I smell something -
now you got it off you know at least
it's not on you maybe you walked in with
it or where was that why father the guy
walked right into it this door we don't
it was more best I just fought like a
feeling creeping up my neck I could feel
that he hit my neck and he tapped me
from buddy's like you're up next when he
looked at me I can see him going like
this [ __ ] set my trance and even that
bit I got you smell the funny goes
nothing it [ __ ] hit him and hit him
late the next day I remember Brad watch
of the piano guy yeah he was farted so
bad that Eddie Griffin was on stage he
did like 20 minutes nobody accused these
poor women poor Brad watch yeah we
always liked it where is he I've seen at
the Hollywood YMCA when I I don't live
in Hollywood anymore but I he works of
the Hollywood why he still plays Anna on
Sundays they don't have the open mic
yeah but I don't forget we torch them
with that because he's one of those guys
I got a dog to get girlfriends
I remember you would ride him pretty
hard
yeah we sits were invincible yeah well
you would pull up I think if he was
outside the parking lot you'd be Watson
yeah because he was a piano player yeah
nights and he'd always say something
[ __ ] crazy to me like are you gonna
do know I know but don't magic a play
don't [ __ ] stand no like you would
always ask
some creepy [ __ ] questions a [ __ ]
just obvious yeah well like Jeff you
don't saying like I was used to Jeff you
just went up with Jeff watch the blowies
drive me crazy but I don't think one day
Watson got a dog just to meet chicks
with but he got the ugliest dog in the
world in the dog was missing a tool he
was God nobody even like the [ __ ] dog
every burger but I still go why don't
you get this dog was it to meet girls
Lisa kinda I got the wrong [ __ ] dog
yeah thank you think you could do
anything right yeah he can [ __ ] up like
a wet like that was just so much go
Sunday nights I didn't for what ten
years baby
like what are you ready soda was the
host yeah we got there well you were
still oh sorry
Oh Shaq oh sure yeah you were like I
think I'm just about done with it yeah
Ari was starting rent as easy was
starting Bobby Lee
Bobby Strom Shire you remember her yeah
what's around kappa roll out the rat
tail braid
yeah but worries bobby stratosphere no
clue there was a couple other women -
who was that there was another woman
that Christine Miller
yeah why the long face Christine Billa
was a soldier she still around Mooney
yeah would take her on yeah she's still
rode Christie but she don't do the bit
about sucking the gearshift to jerk it
off the parking I don't know either way
she's still around she's New York she
was good you know what I always wanted
to ask you in like 2004 I'm riding my
bike along the LA River down by like
frog town and I stopped to get some
water like on my water bottle and I hear
this voice and I look over this fence
but here's you walking out of this
[ __ ] warehouse like this industrial
area and I was like what the [ __ ] is he
doing here where was it that you know
where frog town is I go ahead or you
know what so you know we're like the two
freeway is between the two and the one
tan along the LA River like between like
Dodger Stadium and like Highland Park
you
was just a real [ __ ] I was a member
asking Ari about it music okay you know
who knows when he gonna be gonna doing
anything there
I remember you walked out this I heard
somebody I heard your voice
when I look over this fence did you
leave in this [ __ ] warehouse and
there's just like a totally abandon air
if you have a bunch of [ __ ] stain rags
yeah I don't know why you would remember
it but I don't know if you were I don't
you know whatever you talking about you
got to be more [ __ ] I'm trying to
think of the [ __ ] baby
more specific than the Hollywood Park I
don't [ __ ] it though you know we're [ __ ]
what's uh yeah I mean it's not really
like a distinct area it's like a round
Highland Park and like Glassell Park by
the LA River like on the other side of
the hill from Dodger Stadium huh I like
you know what Fletcher is you know what
Fletcher and Riverside is no just on
north of Silver Lake
I don't like Duncan and Glendale I used
to go to Mimi's and Glendon I don't know
this is that my uncle lives in between
the Mimi's and like when you make the
eggs of the most released but that's it
that's the only reason why every house
places at all I feel like I derailed the
show like that yeah grab the [ __ ]
microphone but it was I was just like
what the [ __ ] cuz I was gonna do a
sketchy area to hear that voice you guys
I remember you guys from the Comedy
Store The Comedy Store was just it was
down it was just a horn it was a place
run by the inmates yeah that when that's
our time there was Mitzi was her health
was failing and I never fraser-smith
used to come in and say man this reminds
me of Brentwood which was they said the
inmates around the asylum and so it was
just a madhouse there was no rules
really it was just insane I never you
would come in you would drive and I'd be
working a lot he would usually be doing
the back door and you say who are you
guys [ __ ] with tonight there could
have been someone in our crosshairs
yeah that was a [ __ ] it was a great
time to develop though cuz you can do
whatever
you know it's become a showcase club
it's got it it's changed a lot but I
went back to doing what the [ __ ] I do in
there yeah yeah yeah I had that fear for
about the last year I kept bitching
little bit I realize it was just an
excuse on my part I kept saying well if
you go down there you can't work out
what's you used to going down if you
can't work out it's still the best place
yeah [ __ ] just go down and do all the
material new material I could get one
thing off that's new go I just going on
there let my mind run away
I used the Comedy Store now it's like
how lucky am I yeah that I could go to
that gym in Florida or mob lolly Gary
that's what that's what the Comedy Store
is I don't put the radio on the way down
to the county store I just dip into a
part of my life but I haven't thought
about a long time just to get my mind
exercising so when I pull into the store
my mind is already moving I don't really
want to only think the only problem I
have with the store is that now we have
people that go down there to see us yeah
so that takes away from the original
planning of it yeah especially you got
you Roman Bert I'll avoid those people
before I go up my thing is to smoke a
joint and get there an hour before my
call time and watch the four carbons
before me that's my Tuesday night
assignment to watch alley wall sometimes
people ordering you though people
[ __ ] cool down like I sit down a
[ __ ] row there's a rule that number
one number one rule don't wanna hear
comments don't [ __ ] talk to women in
that row you know you're not supposed to
talk you're atomic beam that's nothing
you gotta say to me
I understand guess what I understand
that's nothing you gotta say to me look
at my body position look at the
description of my eyes does it tell you
in any form on here hello or
conversation from you when you're in a
room were your last job is to listen
yeah last night I was having a great
time watching Justin Farmingdale
whatever's warm up and some girl tap me
on the shoulder you do my show next I
just want like that in my head look at
the [ __ ] out yeah yeah
that's not them you should know better
don't even [ __ ] say a word to me I'm
in here I'm in the [ __ ] seat I'm
getting butterflies in my stomach I'm
thinking about what I gotta say maybe
they're gonna give me something to play
a lot of of maybe oh she'll give me
something to play off of and you want to
come and tell me some story but I'm
gonna give a [ __ ]
once I'm admits he shows ro does nothing
I want to say to you you won't mind you
put your hand got it I get it I'm ready
to rock and roll down I'm not dinner
afterward we'll take pictures and we'll
talk and I don't take pictures of people
before I go onstage anywhere anyway cuz
you catch a guy with stinky armpit and
now you gotta go onstage that aren't
curling your armpit thinking about
[ __ ] the smell of that [ __ ] garlic
yes what dice calls being in the cage
yeah see I'm in the cage yeah I've seen
about the rapey you wanna talk to people
for when they were in that role did
nothing to talk about
yeah you see me in there back row I
purposely did that on purpose I went
down here an hour earlier so I could sit
in the back and watch the four comics in
front of me and learn something and
learn how I'm gonna gauge my set for the
[ __ ] rest of the night there's
nothing I want to do I don't hear but my
mother I don't want to hear that oh you
felt we found 10 million dollars there
belongs to tell me later I don't give a
[ __ ] wait there well I agree that I
understand why is what's the reason that
you won't stay in the condo in La Jolla
when you were doing La Jolla Comedy
Store does it have to do with the rat or
is that a made-up story the rat was the
mole
the rat was gigantic that I saw and Dave
Marilyn's husband yeah go to bed oh he
caught into the bag he put a trap under
the bed right over their face while
they're asleep I don't know and then
from then on you were around then I went
outside wouldn't like to smoke adjoining
the balcony and I saw the rack before
that was all the same weekend but I
can't sleep I can't sleep with him to
what I was alone Yeah right did you
remember do I did remember we did
Christmas weekend it was you you Sean
Polaski and rent is easy and you would
drive down for the shows and I rent as
easy was up and like you got a stretch
like they were worried you weren't gonna
show up
good it was like I don't know
it was like either your phone was off or
you didn't have a force and like that I
didn't know where you were you showed up
like 1054 you're going up that's it
you're wearing a white long-sleeve shirt
and you set up like a Chinese food
[ __ ] a meal in front you know these
guys got some confidence to eat it you
had the white shirts man off the street
the Chinese food delicious Louis and lo
the keyboards is one of my favorite
stories blue is Harvard around you it he
just keeps going yeah yeah and you're
eating and you trying to break it to go
up kept saying the [ __ ] Bobby Lou you
want a [ __ ] one time you just asked
before and you went up I remember you
murdered it was I do you member that
weekend with Christmas weekend it was
empty but you [ __ ] ever be murdered with
some of the craziest material from here
shot youth and I was like it's currently
was Christmas Eve and you were some of
the craziest dead are you [ __ ] slayed
I remember that that calmly stood the
[ __ ] candy store in La Jolla and this
can't be store now just prepare you yeah
give you this different mindset to give
you a different mindset all the way
around because you're just worried about
what's in front of you yeah I got palm
water in front of me what do I give a
[ __ ] about you have Tuesday night show
at some spaghetti restaurant what made
you think I even give a [ __ ] about your
restaurant I'm here watching Paul Mooney
dying inside thinking about all the
missed opportunities I had I could have
been in the hurts I could have been in
the hurts management program I'm saying
I don't need this I could have been in
the Apple business with my uncle in
Wisconsin making millions right now but
no I'm sitting here at 12:30 on the
Tuesday night waiting for morning to get
off there's eight people it means he's
gonna be four and you want to ask me
about a shell next to they know it's a
spaghetti place get the [ __ ] out of my
face all right I'm trying to figure out
how to pay the reckless its way like
yeah like it's a 29 I gotta figure out
how to pay rent I'm [ __ ] three days
from now
I'm the rent is 400 what am i light the
whole way I'm like the whole way and
we're going into Friday I gotta come up
with a yardstick up to for some cocaine
plus you know I got the edition of
Tuesday plus I got a follow up or movie
right now yeah I mean there's nothing
scarier and going that open there's four
people nothing this is a condom fan I
don't know and then you go home beat up
yeah bury your soul is beat up and you
have to [ __ ] store coke and jerk off
and look out a window and right [ __ ]
question decision only the only thing
that makes that feeling going away is
going up again in front of four people
and doing well and that whole [ __ ]
time people think that we're giving away
[ __ ] lottery tickets here like this
is like yeah come on stage you're gonna
get it in three years even if you do get
in three years you're gonna fall through
at the seven year mark yeah good luck
they're gonna put you in a position
where you're not supposed to be in and
your legs are gonna go right from under
you never seen it before and those
people don't come back the best thing
happened you as it takes 20 years to
make it what he is you don't give up
you've prepared for everything
I prefer that's why I said to myself why
am i [ __ ] around with these other
common like before I shot the Netflix
special which you'll see you'll go it's
terrible why because I wasn't training
at home I was training with all the
other clubs in the area I should have
been training at home I should have been
following Whitney Houston Whitney
Cummings
I should have been following crystally
every night Bobby Lee and rogue unit
Jeff Ross yeah you know that's the
environment you need to be in when
you're ready for it's like a UFC fighter
you gotta train with the [ __ ] black
gazillion and then I am gonna do some I
was thrown into that Tom just thought I
wasn't ready for it
if you want me to lie and tell you how I
was ready for the time you still there's
no way she just like he just like if I
didn't [ __ ] up she just liked me you
know she saw something and on the first
year and a half the first two years bro
every time I left that place I was like
well that'll be my last spot there
that's a bad spot yeah make of Brett's
break said every time because at that
time the word on the street was that she
had a bug and that she listened she was
at home but [ __ ] like me believe
that no we even heard these
she had hidden cameras and [ __ ] we heard
the same thing even later though I mean
so you if you ate a bag of dicks the
original earlier she wasn't there
you still heard about him like you
couldn't wait to go in there on Monday
and bump into it my mistake you're I'm
saying it for her to go I told you that
there that joke you know like [ __ ] she
sold me [ __ ] to do that joke that was
the thing about the Comedy Store that
thought that you try to develop you
don't even know where your next meal is
coming from you know we're right it's
coming from yeah but every time you got
in your car you're like that might be my
last son at the store Jack she might
[ __ ] hear about it
those are dark days man those are relief
what were you like I could be thrown out
of here then I would have nothing this
is literally all I have to say that I
have a credi sort of career or anything
so I tell people like I was totally the
other that was she was around half the
people that are in there that wouldn't
be in there because there was no outside
promotions yeah yeah while you promoted
on Tuesday nights everybody you pull up
that list how to be regular you follow
me yeah [ __ ] I wouldn't be going up you
know I got a lot of guys yeah I wouldn't
be going up because she wouldn't allow
it you had to be a regular Club brower's
Dan tonight the [ __ ] main room was
packed and she threw Jay Davies out of
there he's calm he's the one that people
like but he sold out the room I don't
give a [ __ ] and that was the beauty of a
[ __ ] he sure that she didn't play that
[ __ ] well he's selling out rooms he's
not funny but let's let him headline
anyway
she didn't play that and that Club was
tanking that's why I [ __ ] that's why
[ __ ] that's why with all his [ __ ]
he won't go back there
that hurts to walk out of time just
don't get beat up yeah that hurts that's
why sign for wouldn't go back in there
and she threw a lot of people out of
that that's PTSD Mitzi shore dying a
PTSD because she gave out a ton of PTSD
the people she shattered a lot of people
she shattered people yeah that's why I
tell people don't go [ __ ] around in
there unless you you know say
yeah Richard Pryor has an old joke don't
mess with them Jews
mother you know that's the same thing
they don't go messin with them down
there unless you got all your spots
coward I know I know your girlfriend
told you you're the best could you also
pay the rent do you that yeah okay then
shut the [ __ ] up you know you know you
have to know with your heart that you
did this you did that yeah I did this I
saw a part at this level I fell apart at
this level because every time I was
going to a store right there was a
Saturday Friday night lineup that I
couldn't follow AJ Jamal remember the
name yeah AJ Jamal
and we'll 8c [ __ ] dumb barreras babe
and I had a father
Dom it's always played you know and she
was gonna be there that she was gonna be
there so you would watch her and you
would hope that Eddie Griffin would get
her or one of the girls would get it
yeah be her into the [ __ ] original
room but have you seen her making her
way through the main room your heart
just [ __ ] stop you would just go like
and then she'd sit that bench and you go
up then after three jokes you got a long
16 minutes gee that's how long 60
minutes whatever that [ __ ] booth over
there and she would light a candle so
you'd see your face yeah see how [ __ ]
how much either like you're a titty so
here's what here's what gets ugly I
bombed consistently in the Navy like I'm
a big boy I can tell you guys
legitimately open that door like I love
you never shake that [ __ ] I get emails
from people who have written some wake
up what's that pager people talk [ __ ]
about and there were like Joey and Ari
they laugh good comedians they just kiss
the right rings and all this [ __ ] and I
laugh at those statements because they
have no idea like I started Bob in the
original room
Doug listen she made me a regular Sunday
she put me the original by Monday I got
bumped by Eddie Griffin then they ain't
like a bag of dicks Wednesday how long
had you been doing comedy at this time
square business yeah
square business
I started 91 and she made me a regular
in 97 but I was doing comedy from 93
full timing okay and see you weren't in
it very it was four years but I was a
good four years like I was featured on
the road okay like I was legitimately
featuring of the road I had the power to
walk in there
if these [ __ ] that know I was
already featuring on the road
I wouldn't they're via Stanhope's then
no I got out of my car on a Monday a
dinner I took a shine without Caputo
with the Sycamore in the sycamore line
yeah
that [ __ ] used to be out Caputo
are you getting a night [ __ ] I was down
cumbuco and I went right to the country
store Monday night and as I was walking
in the Comedy Store Eddie Griffin and to
mock from the movie the black clubfoot
movie from the nineties that was popular
the the the Shogun of Harlem just died
two three years ago the guy in the last
drag the last drag the shoe bar whatever
Leroy Bruce Leroy Eddie Griffin Bruce
Lee where I'm like that's [ __ ] Eddie
Griffin loosely Roy I saw dombarris
wheels is up there talking lies behind
the store I got a show like never forget
that you the grace of God substance
suddenly went up then remembered me I
think that was James Steve is deterred
and on that Monday night somebody poured
on Barris over there was maybe two
people the original room and suddenly
talking about Barisan so let me go up
there and I went up there thinking I was
at the garden voice there was 8 minutes
of just death I tried to his off yeah a
couple comics came up to me and consoled
me great yeah
come back next Monday but yeah come back
my ass I became a regular within the but
but my point is this the main room and I
have no reason to lie to you guys
you guys working there I ain't answer
there from 2000 look from 97 to 2000 two
or three and then I figure something up
I figured out but I had to attack them
the same way I attack them in the know
our do our in yo our forget that mr.
nice guy [ __ ] yeah the Sun we use so are
the street fight or is the street always
hands I'm in the old days the Cowboys
used to go down and then the quarterback
was a hot and they would all bounce up
and no down again yeah that second man
spec they were coming to kill you
that's the oh ah I was going into your
main room thinking you know cuz you hit
don't be me there was a dress code to
they'll admit that you got to dress up
if you do in the main yeah yeah we're a
[ __ ] college surely it was a different
set of rules so I didn't think I could
be me like I didn't think I could do
when I was doing the original room of
the Bailey that mean who doesn't have
that vibe that has that vibe where
you're like ah better I'll do this joke
it may be a little too dirty for the
[ __ ] main but it's also like a big
brother will beat you up for 10 years
string keep getting you at the overhead
right one day you actually just go and
you go oh [ __ ]
the second time he does you go oh we
share now every time he throws that
punch I'm gonna come in come in there
with a left a one-two and a kick once I
went like this and figured out the main
room oh and it was about 2003 in the
summer so it took me six years it took
me six years of the dicks the original
was some completely different yeah yeah
I already had it done original room I
was hosting I knew every nook and cranny
everything they do every yeah I do every
trick I do everything yeah say it's to
hell let's give a round of applause for
the troops no kill you using sheep
pellets for that yeah
you need to [ __ ] but the main room was
something different and it took me three
years to learn how to just grab the mic
and just tell them all of something I
looked like I saw you through and so for
beat up like I'm sick and tired beat up
I was like feral force in the burning
bed never will he beat her up the last
time that she was about fire like I'm
not getting beat up in the original room
ever the made room ever again I made a
decision yeah I remember used to be like
take your [ __ ] sticks out of your
asses people yeah I made a decision that
that is it I'm gonna borrow but I'm
gonna let these [ __ ] know who I
am cuz I rent a thing written by the
casting director of The Godfather to
with Donnie Brasco he goes auditions are
not for you to book a job or dishes are
useful to be remembered and I'll never
forget that I go why can't I do that
stand-up comedy I'd love to be the
funniest girl in the room but if I let
my boss no sense of humor at all
but will he leave his balls on fly it
was pretty funny especially the police
think we should smoke on it he was all
white [ __ ] you're gonna remember that
guy the rest of your life every party
you go to you're gonna tell me but the
guys look so once I started thinking out
of the box like that in the mailroom
like these people are better than me you
finally be like yeah absolutely the
original room was like the people who I
could deal with they don't pay rent they
do drug smuggling their own booze in an
area like that but the babe you were up
early up yeah
once I started attacking them there was
a game changer that's it it's crazy how
long it takes you to figure that stuff
out like everybody like it just seems
now you look back you're like what the
hell but who right there was at home
listen to this podcast that's saying
seven years Joey [ __ ] you I bet he'll
become an eternity and get paid oh yeah
that's go to med school yeah they killed
all this [ __ ] I could do is say yeah and
by the way if if you don't have a
[ __ ] burning passion this is the only
thing you could do please become that
attorney because it's gonna be a better
lifestyle for you I started going on so
hard in the main
so [ __ ] hard I started going up there
was a time for I was just caught off in
the main room in 11:45 and then they
weren't gonna get Holtzman again at 1:45
by that time there was that really would
either be in therapy Holtzman in the
main room it's pretty [ __ ] I was just
going that's why what has lost for me
from watching him at the babes I got
memorable he's not going up there
playing games why are you going up there
playing him but let me tell you the
truth what happens when Yearwood year
was the holidays it was that week after
Christmas before New Year's yeah where
there's a lot of action at the store and
I [ __ ] when the original will like
him out there like dog there's nobody
here you gotta go up at the memorable
I'm with there's no real white people
like these people whatever here for
Christmas that go to the ball games yeah
they're wearing their [ __ ] wigs and
sweaters that's the worst week I hate
that way they're really really white and
in your family I mean and there was
listen to me it was 9:45 and there was
no comic stand for the minute
no kind of wakes it off with the baby so
you ready for this one that's one people
you like you find out that there were
comics there and they're [ __ ] there
up and up in the belly on there making
themselves scarce so they come grab me
and my fat little heart is bean Bitsy's
sitting in there oh and there's got to
be sold out there my fat little heart is
beat and then I make the transform a
room it's he's there and I may believe I
only need knowledge I don't want her
even golden to my mind
I just walk right past this [ __ ] and as
I got the [ __ ] door guys Eddie
Griffin not worse at that time who's
walking him it's two nights after
Christmas it's 10 o'clock
there's no comedians of the ability and
either I go next or I follow somebody
guess who just walked in the building
looks at me
hi Chris Wragge
[Laughter]
okay this is it I got a need to go up
and die in front of big feet or follow
Chris Rock what did I get you diet
so I'd never forget you know that step
you go down the bay you walk them you
pay your $15 you walk into the main room
there's like a little step in here like
a dip that you have to go up yeah I take
out a table and cool the contents like
the people [ __ ] taking the drink off
like I see Chris Rock and I just walked
I just keep walking I feel bad I just
fall I got Jinna bike Shh yeah I'm dying
inside that walk in those days I
couldn't even get up like the breathing
like I had a breathing issue yeah and I
was gonna and I was getting anxiety and
now I gotta walk up those little two
steps to get to the main loop thing and
it walked I mean I don't know who the
[ __ ] was on it was suddenly was spotless
clean I [ __ ] went up there I could I
pray to Luigi Jesus please let him do
one more minute so I could catch my
breath because I don't even have the
breath to walk out to the thing when
he's starting to swell from before like
my elbows bleep the [ __ ] table still
white for the jitter of your faces now
push now I look through the curtain and
Chris Rock is [ __ ] sitting next to
mincing it could get worse yet oh [ __ ]
now you're trying to tell me Chris Rock
is it next to bitsy show hogging it up
and I gotta go out there that's what
you're trying to tell me and guys I just
left there and I avoided them I look to
the right to the left and I just want to
I didn't come to talk about the 13
yeah I just leveled that [ __ ] rule I
just went off I talked about all my
beefs God knows and I thought about
[ __ ] on the wheatgrass
god knows what came out of my mouth all
I know is that when Chris Rock went up
when I broke my call out of it was
getting up there that initial surge of
adrenaline anxiety and I just remember
seeing that red light and going oh my
god if I could just squeeze out what
woman in the material this is the
perfect set yeah this is the perfect set
I squeezed it up I took a bow they
[ __ ] went crazy when I broke Chris
Rock up Chris Rock is like I don't know
what the [ __ ] I just saw like he was
just complimented me yeah and my wife
saw that who at the time was my
girlfriend and I remember walking off
that stage and going I just don't know
what just happened whatever happened
happened because I was possessed by a
spirit and I walked out and I never ever
ever thought about it again so I shot
the longest Sharlee he replied to me no
he does he said tons to me about that
Nancy goes I never forgot that night are
you [ __ ] he don't say much
no yeah no I've been at the back door
with he died for 15 minutes
I think five feet from each other did
not a word out of words without a people
so for him to say it to me the first day
at the table read it was the first table
read he gave me five liters man I never
forgot that set that night you didn't
give a [ __ ] he goes home he went off you
went off you just went off I don't know
what you were like with nothing I was
just pissed off and embarrassed because
I would either had to follow you I was
gonna die a slow death yeah any way you
put it they just told me to jump off the
cliff or jump off the bridge that was
the option I had there you know [ __ ]
that's great I mean I remember though
you were like that you were the guy
though like when we were coming up like
people are like I gotta follow Joey Diaz
okay I'll pick my dick up
but no people I mean but you were a
power and I would you the night we you
know the night where the chick took a
[ __ ] on my favorite the store was the
first time I took my dick out up down I
got in trouble didn't get banned but I
got in trouble because I was standing I
was watching I was watching his girl was
drunk and she kept assaulting all the
comedian's and I went over to the side
and I'm like this girl's too pretty to
be insulting comedians and she was on
stage there wasn't dot was Don doing no
no this is Friday oh this is okay 11
o'clock and I had 11:45 and they started
jacking it up like at 11:00 they started
to embedding comics and she was really
pretty and but walk it over to the side
go why is that pretty girl heckling the
[ __ ] I didn't know the dynamic the
comedy clubs I didn't know that women
went out and got drunk to get attention
to the yelling [ __ ] so I didn't
understand the dynamic of it and she
kept saying something that she sets up
to somebody you want to see my titties
and I [ __ ] got pissed off I'm like a
[ __ ] pig those don't comedy show
shows their titties
I'll never forget I had about seven
dollars in my pocket I was scratching
the [ __ ] I mean the [ __ ] shot a
conch jack like seven dollars in my
pocket I couldn't borrow money from my
wife I could borrow but if anybody like
what am I gonna do make money tonight I
live again I went up to the stage then I
go before you [ __ ] say a word lady
don't say a [ __ ] word I don't want to
see your [ __ ] titties unless you
gonna come up here show me the [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't say two [ __ ] words and
this chick that I'm she goes I am gonna
go up to show him that [ __ ] the place
was sold out he [ __ ] walks on the
stage she grabs her mind she goes I'll
show you my [ __ ] if you take out your
[ __ ] and I go deal and the place [ __ ]
erupted and she took off his shirt first
[ __ ] take the heels off and then she
took her pants down to her ankles and
she faced the audience and even opened
up a little noodle why they had out and
I was like I'm like [ __ ] this and I took
my dick out started dancing you know I
remember that there was people watch
from the outside window they had all
come into the sides and Rogin when Bobby
Lee were throwing money at me when I
kept picking up every [ __ ] like that
Monday at bitsy called bitsy she [ __ ] is
yeah I was coerced
that's all I was chorus I told her she
challenged my honor its he loved all
that [ __ ] she loved that time all can
wait talking about she took out a [ __ ]
and she said that I was a [ __ ] nut if
I didn't take out my dick
she said that yeah okay it's crazy
though sometimes like that's the kind of
[ __ ] you have to do to survive
a set in those late-night spots
sometimes you have to [ __ ] it sometimes
it has to turn into a circus I don't
forget complain in one night at the
great Brian whole trip I know what the
[ __ ] I might do another of my life on a
Wednesday night wait that new one a one
15th spot and all for those speed I want
to do it but a sign out in the front
the only people sign up a spot hundreds
if not more people into perspective for
me I was like okay yeah like I [ __ ]
get it like that was that was very bad
that put everything in there I don't
care what spot I go up you know yeah I
was always very lucky to be like at that
time the Laugh Factory was the hot club
but I didn't give a [ __ ] I didn't want
to be in the latter fact that the Laugh
Factory was NBC's okay no I mean when we
go how many times I open mic to like
like twice you have to wait outside for
like six hours and the [ __ ] then you'd
go up in this guy back in the day this
guy now I think his name was Harvey you
would sit at a [ __ ] school desk on
the stage with you and you even got to
approaching edgy language what whoa wait
a second timeout like Mike they would
[ __ ] jump the life are you god you
[ __ ] oh my god Harvey that's right
Jamie said you happy you got to work
clean otherwise you'll never work that's
right he told me the same thing gave me
a lie they do it they're gonna be out of
there the first [ __ ] that cuz that was
the first open point I went to the
Comedy Store Day and The Laugh Factory
was Tuesday and I stood on line all day
what's his name drops off water for you
brother Woods the the white comic the
one that always touches his head he's
Jewish he plays the piano on stage I got
problems he's like I talked to my
psychiatrist I don't know Richard
whatever his name is he would yeah yes
he was really good you better bring your
suntan lotion if you want to know what
they're well then people would drive up
and down Sunset everyone you know and
they'd see you [ __ ] sick of us right
there they totally have to come back so
I never came back and then the Improv
gave me love right off the back of the
Latino tonight
yeah calling for the schedule so I spent
a quality I had no beefs there so ha ha
right you were at that no no no I didn't
get to the haha to Madonna was a [ __ ]
family
oh yeah I mean I lived in Harlem it was
the club business
you were gardener right yeah what's the
house gardener yeah gardener was right
across the street I'll do gardener and
everything I did was wrong god no it's a
karate school in the corner
I had the [ __ ] a little sports car
with a dragon with the ponytail back to
the conahey have the garages behind
those buildings where he has his garage
because he collects some type of cars
without you oh wait
who told us Ralphie Bay who told us that
you Ralphie may he and you used to [ __ ]
with McConaughey
McConaughey had his car collection back
there I don't know City you got Ralphie
used to scream out there that was a
great McConaughey all the time until
McConaughey like lost this yeah oh you
really think of it better so that maybe
would 99 you ready yeah it was Josh
whorfin Vista
it was one Street over Ralphie man guard
it was Victor Paulo at Mitch Hedberg on
see Robo dealer and she is and Doug
Stanhope with bunker so Wow okay that
was all consecutive blocks and these
guys I would see all these guys we would
see each other at Ralph Ralph that
Ralph's is all [ __ ] comics up place
across the street with the headshots
yeah yeah and the thing I died that he
left the Asia wife that was really cute
that she closed it up eventually he was
like an older man with an asian wife she
was very sweet
that's what we got our head shots I got
my hair cut there that hotel what's the
name of that hotel like sunset hotel is
your [ __ ] ass [ __ ] I lived
in that neighborhood with the hamburger
stand was still there and the pips
you standing out there they did that's
American oh that where that bar is now
this what's the two brothers to the
movie mm about American Gigolo was a
very good pit yeah I know you're talking
about the Hughes brothers the
documentary but yeah yeah I know that's
one like pym culture but yeah it was
really good yeah it exposed that
hamburger place and hamburger place we
walked plants on the hamburger place
running sunset right in between rock and
roll routes and no compadre yeah was
that hamburger stands and then closes it
was closed for years and God knows it
it's it's not the gas station but it's
that little mall next to the gas station
that gas stations that I guess that was
a tire place it's a tire place now but
it was a gas station and the guy ran it
for his father by himself so I would
stand by the quarter and wait for him to
go outside and pump gas for people and I
would go ahead and grab a soda and stick
by him but on account and take a pack of
cigarettes any cigarettes and he would
let me charge the sodas are the urban
[ __ ] like candy cakes that's a great
day but that was no I don't know it was
different now though changed when I when
I
I live there there was still a little
bit of criminal element I remember there
was a night what like what year that you
lived in I lived there I lived there my
whole time I moved out just this past
year so what you've seen like 2003 or
you would we die d8 there were hookers
so it was it that was like starting to
leave when I was there that was pimping
hookers oh we did see a lady not get
abducted yes some guy was trying to
shove her in his truck kidnap her and we
look out the window because II had a bay
window that overlooked we were just
screaming and we see this guy he's
ragged this lady and got away we were
like what the [ __ ] we had somebody
robbed
yeah it's chicken gunpoint we were
watching TV in my living room
FIFA still knocks on my window I go
these [ __ ] idiots always leave their
keys I lived in the front of the
building I go just ignore it
we're watch the TV and I hit please let
me get you crying and I go oh [ __ ] I'll
open the door she were just robbed at
gunpoint
uh-huh two feet from us and we would
walk that neighborhood like nothing at
night cuz we cross your building yeah we
walk behind that whole the whole sunset
to avoid the cops and then walk behind
Sierra both Hannah and her son in those
days at 7-eleven so so be it'll - yeah
we were trying to catch we'd be [ __ ]
up there was a liquor store lay around
the corner yeah I stumbled the walk and
coked up to the gills to that [ __ ]
liquor store I started but not gonna
Ralphie's door it's 99 him telling me
that I pick black on his door the night
before last summer he was looking for
companionship she door-to-door camping
that's impressive
work at he killed the hooker what's they
murdered the hooker on that corner that
they cleaned up that whole day but there
was a night I was cuz I had the big the
big windows went for my living room but
in my bedroom - I live right on Gardner
and I was always scared on the ground
level someone's gonna throw a [ __ ]
brick through that window my bed was
right there and so I like to something
the morning I came home from the store
I'm going to sleep and I was like in
that state where you're like kind of
asleep but kind of not and I heard
someone say give me your [ __ ] money
give me your [ __ ] money [ __ ] and so
I go oh [ __ ] I sprang up I have like you
know the curtains I open him up I see
this guy [ __ ] punch this
in the face in the street like oh [ __ ] I
get on the phone call 9-1-1 like Sir can
you seem like like 30 feet like you
gotta get here and I see a [ __ ]
helicopter come and hit him with the
[ __ ] light and in my mind like oh
[ __ ] I called that in and uh so I don't
I don't can't see what happens they let
go like they like keep going in like
five minutes later Ari Shaffir text me
and that [ __ ] weirdo he you followed
the West Hollywood Police like their
Twitter page or something he's like
copters came your block guy got arrested
for having a gun it was a pimp shaking
down a [ __ ] hooker had a gun on him
got arrested and it was like yeah two in
the mornings [ __ ] crazy
yeah they pushed all those hookers down
further like they started clearing out
West Hollywood and just started pushing
him down towards like Western we were
getting an eye one night me and a girl
and another girl was snorting coke and
the first floor a garden we're going
deep it's got to be 5:00 in the morning
and all of a sudden was sitting there
we're here you've been sucking my dick
for twenty minutes and all I got his
teeth suck that dick correctly look at
each other well we don't like somebody
through their voice like did you just
say that who invited Jeff Dunham and we
looked outside guy was with this hooker
on our heads and these are sucking the
guy's dick you think I just told you
stop using your teeth [ __ ] that's how
[ __ ] nuts that the head was right off
gardener too if you went down towards
like Santa Monica oh yeah that's that's
was the vast oh yeah they used to be a
bar a restaurant across the street from
there
when we first got the hele if you didn't
want to go to rock the world Denny's
stand home we'd go there for breakfast
they had a back and smoked cigarettes
and they used to keep it open at night
and somebody got raped there something
then they had to close the place like we
used to go to restaurants where play a
little we got rated to that like a guy
got raped
we gotta close it that true buddy rate
some deals today the planes were used
for me Jenny's maybe they'd rather eat
in a rape place at this great place is
run by like Hawaiians the best the best
breakfast was that day bud but that
night it was a double that's a ball I
never went to the ball but I guess some
guy it was like a rapey place for guys
it was rich guys the guys are going they
get loaded a good luck to be is there
new marketing campaign from right there
any Bravo
did he oh he did I yeah yeah from Astro
burger right there at the corner you all
you had to do is walk 25 yards next to a
body shop is that why I got into jujitsu
teaching self defense for the holohan
restaurant that was crazy doesn't and
that's been at the store that's the
first yeah yeah what possession because
I was probably writing see basically the
spots at the store were like we're not
gonna make it as comics doing this [ __ ]
you know you couldn't get like I mean
basically doing stand-up was just trying
to display your writing ability more or
less you know and so I came out here
because I wanted to write movies which
you know was kind of what did you major
it alright well so I didn't go to I went
to college when I was like 21 because my
mom really won me to a college but I was
selling cars I was racing cars and I
thought hey this is it but then I got an
accident that [ __ ] didn't work out for
me and I was like I don't want to sell
cars the rest of my life
there's no way so I was I enrolled in
this film school in a Chicago and then
after that I did my last semester out
here in LA and then literally after
school ended I just I did stand-up I
first opened like at the Comedy Store
and then I just I was writing movies I
met him and we started writing movies
together and we had we haven't gotten a
movie baby yet
what's your process I mean if we're
writing yeah you guys have a process
Nora last year uh I mean stuff in terms
of like some do it like whenever we have
meetings people would always ask like
how do you write because so many there's
two people some people write like one
writes and then they hand it off to the
other guy we always write together
you just sit right we're used to
literally sit right next to each other
and then like literally type and then
talk like literally right next to each
other on a couch and just watch the
screen and do it but then we started
doing like screen sharing and stuff like
that and the technology yeah fit on your
own code but you know like and we were
so deep in that but the industry has
changed but man we can't yeah we're
we're closed on a lot of a lot of things
we could always get a good agent or a
good manager because we always had good
material but it was just like you know
it's like everything shifts at one point
they're looking for this and you have
something like that but by the time you
get everything set up and go into pitch
they're on to something else and so I
don't know I think at this point you
know you're just tired of playing the
game and like the more [ __ ] that you can
just do on your own without having to
rely upon a studio or anybody a network
to like get your [ __ ] out there I mean
you know it's like doing do your own
specials or doing your own thing man
it's so we change the movie business you
make a good movie though that's great
but guess what there's a lot of people
made a movie out you haven't made three
or four good movies to get people to pay
attention to you know Tommy you get one
good special one shitty special you know
what you need all of them to be good
because so I think writing is a
beautiful thing I'm horrible at like I'm
horrible at it but I like it because you
control your own destiny absolutely you
can write [ __ ] put it away keep tuning
it up and you get that tide comes back
and said the guy who had what was that
show on ABC about the wives in the one
block and that was like a script II and
for [ __ ] ten years there's a lot of
guys like then they go into a pitch
meeting didn't thing you know what else
you got they say that you every [ __ ]
mean you'll pitch him a whole [ __ ]
the movie three months yeah you
working out this pitch every word of
every [ __ ] joke you do it all for
them they're right you know you can tell
they're really not paying taxes what
about the [ __ ] thing I just gave you
and I spent three months of my life
I'll think about that but I'll show ya
that's when you know how long have you
guys been ready together I mean
0:03 is like when we stay you know it
was it took a while for us to kind of
like get good material together it's
crazy like Oh three you started with
always 17 like so hey hey whatever the
[ __ ] that means you guys been running
together for 15 years yeah so in about
two years will you look at the end of
the day you know what you're the kiss of
death you saying we can't let's split
and also the month lady we're gonna call
hey we have a meeting with you three
years ago
I just got over 600,000 do you have
anything else you like yeah hold on let
me call him back on the phone that's
what happens uh yeah it's you know it's
waiting for the miracle to happen that's
the crazy thing about writing is like
people like you know if you look at the
career it's like what what they don't
see is all this great things that you
have written that haven't gone anywhere
or are still waiting they don't people
don't realize like the process even if
you even if you had a show now and it
got picked up it's gonna be three four
years before it [ __ ] even debuts if
you have to deal with all the
development then you go casting then
there's pilots and there's test
screenings and it's all this [ __ ] it's
like yeah anything ever gets maiya when
we did so anytime any lawyer gets
involved like even though we've done
[ __ ] on the web it takes forever for
four months five that's forever I mean
yeah the last thing we had six months
for just just lawyers to agree on
specific wording okay I don't like this
wording and I go back on that for
[ __ ] to three weeks and like you're
just sitting there you're like I need a
[ __ ] check man like agree and like
they're just like no and it just gets
crazy but this town for me it I think
for both of us been great kicking you in
the balls but like right like a day
after you kicked in the balls you find a
dollar bill and it always gives you
something to stay around you see in the
game yeah just enough to be like wow
this is white this light at the end of
the tunnel you look at like Leslie Jones
who got [ __ ] what you got on SNL at
47 40
yeah 48 years old so it's like Leslie
Jones on SNL at 47 years so all this we
do cast member we worked with her in
2012 on this thing we added like I mean
yeah I mean she's like wouldn't return
our call our manager cuz she's always
like bill collectors coming so fudge is
like oh I didn't it was the opportunity
and then yeah and we just did this
little thing with her and like yeah I
mean she was just like happy to do like
she's a gal [ __ ] yeah man like nobody's
coming to me to do [ __ ] and she was a
through the powerhouse comic though she
was like she was tougher than [ __ ]
nails but it's the thing they just goes
to show even if you like there's guys
that go in I mean you free also like he
were just [ __ ] you would crush but
you have to be like the darling of the
industry you gotta you gotta check all
the boxes you gotta have the look you
got to be able to go on TV like if
you're doing what you do and being you a
lot of times that involves like some
sometimes you're gonna interact with the
crowd sometimes you're gonna do like but
they want [ __ ] that they can throw on TV
you got to do quick jokes that people
will get right away if you want to do
it's night show in order to build you up
in order to do this it's it takes a lot
longer when you're just trying to be you
but look what happened with the end of
it yeah I mean okay when I got here I
was told I wasn't a little fit the type
not clean it was it was very gut
wrenching for the first two or three
years very frustrating because I didn't
have one of the qualities they were
looking for not one of the qualities
that they were looking for but I had one
quality that kept me in I was on to
something
I wasn't funny I was out to something
that's why I'm it's he can give me spots
I was out of the subject do you notice
anything I didn't fit that you know what
I would I got hit all these blonde funny
good-looking guys were getting deals
good-looking guys getting deals I've had
three minutes of material and couldn't
hold they're all at the Comedy Store
number one guy in particular he looked
like Steve Reeves had died and come back
to life 20 times better than him this
guy was gorgeous I forget what his name
was and every time he walked into a
comedy club we had to Jerusalem that's
how much they protected his
but this guy was a guarantee [ __ ]
television star and one night they made
a [ __ ] crucial mistake they set up a
showcase for him at The Comedy Store or
like a benefit and he had a follow dice
who and I'll never forget but he fell
apart at the seams and I never saw that
gonna get him
you know so I knew I had one thing those
we had I was on to something
and number two I was at the store so you
know what you don't want me to go to
Montreal cuz you think I'm too dirty you
don't fit your little scheme really
doesn't matter to me you don't want me
for Comedy Central doesn't matter I'm at
the store I'm over there I may not be
with the Gambino's but I'm with the
Lucchese this we just figured out how to
[ __ ] hook up with cocaine so we'll
pick it up up of steam with the new year
we're gonna have three million the way
you battle up against you so that's how
I always looked at it looked differ
every year it was different like once
2000 came in 2001 it looked like I
didn't have a chance but then they told
you you have a with you booked
television you have a chance so I booked
a pilot nothing happened I booked bass
ketball
nothing happened I booked the De Niro
movie I was already with that one I was
already getting the [ __ ] suit to walk
into all that [ __ ] was [ __ ] so it's
like every year they rewrote the rules
on you to what you need to do to get to
that next level and also you think like
oh once I get in at CAA or we were at
one of the big agencies they do anything
for us I mean then you realize now
you're the lowest guy out there [ __ ]
Ross there and now people say well
where'd you guys come from we came from
CAA oh we came from ICM well I'm Joe
show up and [ __ ] Woodland Hills if
they couldn't do that before you yeah
well anything I'm gonna do what am I
gonna do fiend so now you're on your own
and you're pretty much shot but see I
believe it is something completely
different I believe that now you have
the Internet yeah absolutely
I believe that now you have the Internet
you know what you want a book you got it
you want to read right you could write
any book that much
[ __ ] you want to shoot sketches or
something like that'd be yeah you could
[ __ ] him go there look for money and beg
for money and get $50 and the Go Go will
come out and never the [ __ ] that's not
what you want to [ __ ] do you want to
shoot videos or something keep the money
low but to shoot that you got to use
either actors to the note or actors that
have internet presence every [ __ ] day
there's a new web series and what
happened they got done the pizza low why
because number one you never told nobody
about it you didn't prepare them you
didn't prepare it you didn't let him
know was coming you pull on this guy's
Facebook page you're waiting for us to
sell itself web series could do great in
this economy because I'm going to work I
would love to be able to watch a
seven-minute clip five days a week every
day at work with it with a [ __ ]
ending on Friday I would love to have
that and every it comes out every
[ __ ] day at 6 a.m. so basically all
you're doing is shooting tell episodes
and cutting a bit the 7 minute clubs 5
days in a row that would [ __ ] kill
right now yeah that's what we I mean
that was what when we first started
doing stuff we did stuff with run is
easy we did a webseries we did a couple
seasons of it and it was a big hit like
I mean you know if you can get half a
million or a million views on something
it's [ __ ] I mean you do it as well as
Comedy Central's doing and so I'm yeah
that's whereas it's kind of like yeah
you just got to do everything yourself
now is like we we just so we would not
here's the beauty of it here's the thing
that nobody really understands that you
do everything yourself since day one
true at the end it's when they ship you
in that casket you're like my agent was
great but all he did was piggyback the
seeds that I planted you always have to
plant seeds that's why that's why
there's such a high failure rate here
because people sign with an agent they
think that's it the end-all be-all
not me I bought backstage every [ __ ]
Wednesday if it was at that curse island
7-eleven at 4:55 it was at my house at 5
o'clock by 8:00 in the morning next one
and I had my envelopes out for student
films you follow me that was different
you me and everybody else that I'm i buy
that yeah and guess what I saw those
envelopes coked out to the gills
I'd be snorting
right and [ __ ] resident in the
envelope [ __ ] looking at the envelope
but the next Morty has cooked up as I
was and mailed those [ __ ] things so
even though the agent kept telling me no
you're not gonna get in for this no okay
let's just see cuz the casting directors
job is to get the job done and get the
job cast she doesn't need more
politically more fire and you're the one
for that movie send in your autumn
edition tape stop talking [ __ ] that's
there's money in this town absolutely
buddy yeah every different level you
guys are a [ __ ] hair away from being
millionaires you cutting away your great
writers I like your stuff you're a
little out there you're a little bit
[ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
yeah you see the people around you grow
have you left yeah mm to reach to that I
would see re at Ralph's when he when Ari
lived on Sunset and and you have a
[ __ ] cart full of me and then what
the [ __ ] are you doing he was buying
meat that was like expiring or like on
that day for very cheap and he would
freeze at all 30 pounds of me so he was
sitting at only $1 he was just so broke
but he was buying [ __ ] old me to
freeze and I mean now and I look at all
right now and he's a [ __ ] and it's a
little different what's the difference
that he did was he he finally stopped
playing the game
yeah was it that's well that's well
that's it you got something you got to
wake up you go I yeah what am i doing is
it looking game it's like I told you
I've listened every week I got an email
guys every week I get that one email
okay and it's a how you do let's see the
mister
oh we love your podcast it starts off
[ __ ] complement through your [ __ ] and
then it goes into I'm shooting blah blah
blah
would love to have you on this product
project thing you sometimes you click
the link sometimes you say you can't
whatever the [ __ ] that comes my way is
so [ __ ] bad and you know when you
read it you know by the structure yeah
like I know as soon as I see structure
you're done this is dope wet
well you've read so I mean
that's the fear I lose you know when
there's no I see like I got what a
couple of weeks ago there's a lot of
dough attached but I read the thing like
oh this angel how much will you read
before you're like I know this sucks
four pages yeah five babies do you stop
and he really like that's it I'll come
back later on I'll think about what I
read yeah we come back later but I know
in the first year for pages well it's
something
what I want to do yeah like I was with a
guy that we were trying to pitch
something and I would talk to him I
would this is very difficult I would
talk to him and explain to him what I
want and what I didn't want to do he
came back with this whole thing he
started telling me all these movies he
referenced I [ __ ] hate it
so all this [ __ ] II had so the middle of
nine pictures I go I don't want to do it
cuz that's not what I want to do then
what do you want to change this is what
I have to change this is what I have we
don't I just know I've been here long
enough so I know you know buddy Bob
things I've read I'm Shirley Bob things
I ran after The Sopranos we're The
Sopranos are getting ready to get off
the end you have the idea Billy Bob
things I'm sure everything that was ever
going into production came 30 years no
idea
you have no idea so I know the first
floor five pages you hate being
judgmental but you gotta look at the
time yeah well you spend on [ __ ] I
think I look at what that moves the do
for me guys I'm gonna get know yelled if
I was 32 I do the heartbeat what does it
do to be acting next to this you know
acting next to this guy this guy's don't
know IMDB what am I gonna gain from this
not gonna gain that he's taking me away
from your family make me do something I
want to really do you're not gonna lift
the rock at this point even if you lift
a rock I really don't want to do it it's
not it's not gonna be good because your
heart's not out really to it you got
other revenue - I mean you got stand-up
you got you know II mean it's not like I
[ __ ] know but I got disenchanted with
acting years ago like once I saw first
of all I was I never came here from
Broadway so I'm not that guy but I did
enjoy it I did like it as a you know
what's his name said that whatever
Susy hasn't when you go from field to
field I love doing stand-up guess what I
don't do it for the two weeks a year
I don't even back in the day you were
like I gotta get off planes you were
like I'm done you're like I don't do
Sunday shows yeah and I gotta get the
boy out of here yeah they know I paid my
dues so you know it's like that but it
keeps me fresh I love doing stand-up but
as far as typing 10 years ago I think a
little actor love this yard by 2007 I
was done with actor unless you come at
me with 10 and I decided that like I was
getting all this [ __ ] thrown at me
YouTube stop this I was like I don't
want to do this stuff and I baited a bit
for though just to put no then they
offered me grudge match which sucked but
it still gave me a level up yeah you
know so I don't bite doing those things
that's gonna help be a level up I get to
experience different people but to be
honest at this point my life to work
with length subdued three days I got to
drive to Calabasas I can't shoot my
podcast you're gonna get it up like you
gotta get it no I can't do it I'm not
even interested yeah so fun weird but my
heart goes out to you guys because I
believe you but in the [ __ ] game in
the trenches all it is is freaking with
it that's all of it and also if you've
adapted your life like violet my life
style is so cheap now I can live off
anything like if you don't give a [ __ ]
if they paid it it's like a chariot of
the Sun yeah it's the most important
thing is that you love what you do and
you didn't get trapped back and [ __ ]
you know still sweeping at the hotel you
didn't get trapped back and Boston where
the [ __ ] you came from you don't know
how to do that's the [ __ ] that's the
most important about being out here is
keeping that dream alive in' also once
you get a certain age and all your
friends that do have money and they're
just like all they ever want to hear is
the stories of what you've been up to
because they got there's nothing like
they have money now but it's like can't
go anywhere because they're working all
the time can't do anything two weeks out
of the year that they want to go on
vacation they're too tired from their
job the whole year they [ __ ] want to
go anywhere probably like the medicine
it's better than what did they have I
agree sometimes it's [ __ ] agree it's
better than what
then to have that's why you've been a
[ __ ] think about it really good you
know cuz one day they might come to you
Danish an allele and go hey we love that
sec time idea and find out for eight
years for 30 weeks on that here you work
14-hour days I mean you hear a lot of
[ __ ] you know comics act whatever and
they're like that my glory days were
when I was struggling creatively I mean
obviously money-wise and all that but
well yeah I mean we even know like just
of stuff we've worked on and then you
start getting notes and you're like man
this was so much more fun when we were
just writing the [ __ ] that we willing to
write all this [ __ ] I can give a
Frenchman to talk about if I could turn
the clock back and get to sleep on
Ralphie may is flowing Ralphie was broke
if I can go back to with Ralphie was
broke that was the best times I had here
the only person I knew only half the
time was Rohit and not really he was
just on Newsradio remember years ago I
was a dog tour guy and I you were just
like when you work that job you just sit
I didn't know if you very well at all
yeah remember seeing you talk to Logan
and he had this like ten minute
conversation with Rogan about what are
you gonna do if the apocalypse comes are
like some [ __ ] like a flood or an
earthquake and you're like I was trying
to send them up to Robin he's like you
gotta have a man yeah you gotta have ten
different places that ATM system is set
up to shoot down some day you're gonna
go I'm a cat and your balance is given
to zero if they're not gonna know what
the [ __ ] when I was the POW without
China
your [ __ ] when he was looking at you
like this guy is the [ __ ] you would like
an hour long plan oh you're gonna do it
he's like I have no idea I can see the
rule you're like oh [ __ ] I better
[ __ ] oh yeah how about conspiracy
theory whatever the [ __ ] I'm a realist
one day that's what those ATMs or for
you can have every single time you have
invested in those things and one day the
power something off I get computer and
all the files are gonna get erased and
you
they're looking for you 9,000 this it'll
be zero on top of zero and they can't
they don't know what's gonna happen what
hap
it weather's gonna [ __ ] universe you
didn't down clown it the wood whatever
that one look at one cloud my dick okay
I got a yard in those yard deposit boxes
all over the country in case I gotta fly
into there and make a pitch now close to
the airport
boy howdy you [ __ ] you see jelly
with the shovel you know she map it's on
a cereal box [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] the bank I
trusted like the [ __ ] you guys was a
real pleasure thanks for having fun
we could talk about the touch top topics
I wanted to talk to you about whenever
you want
how about right [ __ ] we don't want to
write for buddy and with a you write
[ __ ] for it that you don't want to write
for money you wish you had a 9 to 5 day
job
listen there that's like where they shot
this left flicks think they like the
first five minutes you gotta write about
your life and go through and I was like
you killed me oh they gave you they're
gonna be the same cuz there's only 30 28
minutes so they want your first five
minutes to be a little bit about
yourself to introduce yourself
but then the lineup they changed them up
so I like get a ball with [ __ ] you know
I'm saying so it was like you learned a
lot
you learned to stick to your [ __ ]
guns when you wouldn't you just rather
when I'm in those you just rather fail
on your own [ __ ] your own stuff yeah
you don't mean I'd rather go down on
your own sword and someone say hey do
this and you're like that's exactly that
I've died I died the slow [ __ ] death
I die the slow [ __ ] bad I mean I just
I mean I have a feeling I'm gonna watch
it here you've killed the DA I die a
slow death I think it's just what I'm
doing now is completely different it's
so weird like I'm back to 2006 at The
Comedy Store dangerous again okay
dangerous not giving a [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] about what comes out of my mouth
if it hurts your feelings it just
makes a little difference I'm 55 I got
one foot in the grave what I'm gonna
have appeal and what do you do to me
there you gotta come back and be my
camera 36 years later you just suck my
dick you know say so yeah joke to the
party big [ __ ] deal on me please dick
though no harm done he just choked you a
little because you were a dumb [ __ ] in
the closet room she's lucky than you or
the closet room of my hometown they
wanna put [ __ ] jackets on top of you
[ __ ] in the ass there would have been
no joke and I'm grabbing what the [ __ ]
is wrong with these people
dirty sick she is laying it on you want
to come out and say a judge grabbed you
really even put this baby please taking
you month everybody know there wasn't
big beer when he went home up skate what
the [ __ ] is going on I love you guys
thank you very far you find a said find
a podcast at Danish Tony on Twitter
account Danish Antonio ah danger Neil
Instagram you can find me on Ryan O'Neal
comedy on Instagram I got yeah I got a
new Twitter at as well as our own but I
got a at B Jeff Danis thanks thanks for
having us thanks so much I want to take
Danish you know deal for coming out
today
also don't forget Boston at Foxwoods is
sold out right now all I got to work
with is West Palm Beach improv October
11th through 13th and hilarity is
October 25th through the 27th now like I
told you the beginning of the show
listen since I started the podcast
people always want advice and take some
who's gonna win but get well Kabhi but
listen I don't know if I knew was gonna
win I wouldn't be here doing a [ __ ]
podcast every week the truth is I don't
know who's gonna win well if you think
you know you gotta check out my bookie
why because who you're betting on is
just as important as will you bet wit I
would only recommend the service to the
church family that's been good to me
that's why I'm urging you to make your
way to my bookie cuz you win they pay
that's it
they got it game live betting and over
and others on fantasy for each scored
and the most rewarding player perks in
the business
my bookie slim would do better is all
day they want to give you and everybody
else especially
family the first the best possible
service what we will do is this if
you're willing to deposit after seven
o'clock Eastern Time that's four o'clock
California they'll give you an
additional $25 FreePlay deposits over a
hundred hours yo the Dodgers six games
away join down my bookie will match your
deposit dollar-for-dollar use promo code
Church to activate the office or visit
my bookie online today
that's my bookie my Bo ok ie and don't
forget to use the promo code Church when
creating your account and claim up to a
thousand dollars in free play who's
better than that nobody if you wanted to
hold down until 7 o'clock they give you
an extra 24 hours alright so it's up to
you but I'd wait till after dinner to
take the extra money you play you win
and you get paid that's a bad bookie
does I want to thank on it again I want
to thank David shall deal I want to
thank my babe add the fried you for
helping me out I don't want to thank you
guys for being [ __ ] family and for
giving us a chance it's listening every
week have a great week I hope this gets
you a week [ __ ] started correctly and
I'll see you [ __ ] in two days
stay black kick that Billy